Mr. Seiji Aino It's
sudden, but
you say you won't kiss
Please go home, the god of death is in time
Prime minister candidate
regardless of religion
[music]
dj
animejapan
ani came
can
ani
dee who came in
can you do
tan tan
male
voodoo
[music
] what do you think this is
[music]
there's no table, it's different  It's a dissmart day Chiki throat
Please look inside for now
[Music]
My back room is also a
little
bit from the ripoff As you can guess, my name is written on this notebook I won't kiss you within 24 hours
[music]
nan I
'll die if you don't notice
me go eat it re
Yo
5 Isn't she just a [ __ ]?
But if I kiss you, will I be charged a high price later
?
4 Let's take a closer look at this store
Well then, let's get started Oh, the
walls are high Oh, are
you satisfied with this
?  Through
Then write down the name of the growth I'll write down the name of the growth in Haki-cho, the neighboring city Haki-cho Haki-cho Haki-cho Haki-cho Hokkai It's over,
I'll turn on the TV
[music]
2 acer After this, the couple will settle within 24 hours
Even if it's right away, why is it a man, my child anyway?
Seriously, I made a mistake
I'm
going to get out [music] ana It's almost as close as you can get through It's a beautiful pr
because I thought I wrote your name wrong, but you were there for 4 days
z blitz It's not at least something  As an apology, I'll provide you with the thread
that you requested.
Let's make an effort, too
Desire, the owner, and the hula group have fallen down --
please don't stand up, it's okay.
e 6 e
That's amazing, isn't
it Update your personal best Is that Hiyama that you want to be a kid regardless of your own will?
I don't really see you anymore than I want.
I'm used to it in the sky, haven't you noticed
?  It was only a minor accident that
I kissed you Goon I did that but ah
ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
!
I won't forgive you, but where did the wall and solo
Hanyu come from
?  It's the base salary of 'Is it okay?'
This is the line.
Isn't
it fine? A man should think about
it.
Even if you're the type to withdraw, you'll have no choice but to avoid it for the rest of
your life.The woman in Isobetsu will change her name.
Method
Yes, if you change your name
Ah, it's because of you that you're the one who made the first money hit by living together.
I was born
tee
ni
[music]
ana I
didn't realize it at all
Why did you pretend to be like that until now?
You must not have noticed
I was so happy I thought you loved me more than anyone else
That's why I've been waiting for you to confess your
love
So, before this happened, I should have eaten even if
I wasn't confident.  I'll tear it up so that it doesn't come off Exercise def
I'm looking at a delicious wall that I can't live in
Interesting stories can't be done Who
are
you?
[Music] It's only for a
moment, but your feelings were connected, so if it was the previous month, it would be 2 and Super Jaguar
[Music]
rar
[Applause]
Number 4 The couple born from the kiss note was definitely canceled
7 minutes
And you are me  I thought I was going to put a Shinigami on and stick it in 5 haa
[music]
by a here
Shimidi Scaspre seems to be autumn Well, but it's a flower cupid, but that's why from now
on please choose a grid instead of a stain paper
Cupid  In other words, in order to summon us, yes,
the power of the note will keep you two together
forever.  2
Haaaaaah, wasn't it just a dream?
When you covered me up a while ago, it
suddenly came to me. Yeah, I'm a player, so I can't really do it, but
I want to find out more about what this feeling is.
It's okay to strongly cut off crimes
z I'm white, so I went to get a refund, so I
got this navigator, you guys won't do it
.
No matter how much you blend in too much, you did something
It's okay, let's go together, so please admit that we're lovers in the first place
.
No, I'm going to pass it through a cola, and
right now I'm borrowing the power of Uta Ward from Miu-san's body, but when
my boss stops, does that face stop
you?  Okay
baby bar It's the
rainy season
So
of scold me  Cheating isn't that bad now, but it's
not
cool, but that's one more person.
Then, let me tell you an important story about the future of Kuri and you.
It's not that often that an angel becomes a couple, but the
husband or you later became an angel parenthesis party, so I don't know.
In your case, you're a temporary disciple, so if you go to hell, you
'll lose your soul.  Why don't you look embarrassed, so
I asked for support from a distance,
but I refused Who would have withdrawn from such
a little monkey?
reason
Well, if I do anything, then what should I do after the powder like yesterday?
Even if it's
dirt, it's important to think about it properly before drawing workability It's going to be a very important thing
Idol jam grill cooker pro I'm going to see myself too Subaru
Zenzai Defense University
Yes I'm relieved
4  Waiting for the day
I will be indebted to various things from now on
10 Thank you for your
support
That's what I said,
ah ah ah
I won't do it on my own than the song of my dreams
So don't be so hoi hoi
oh I was seen by
someone who said it again
Please yeah it
's okay It
's not your modus operandi  That's
why I'm dating a woman, but I'm studying with a woman 2
[Applause
] Please
, you don't want to work too
much.  It's important,
eh, what
did you
write
?  Do you need disturbing music to appear?
The only thing that makes that motion dependent is stopping.It
doesn't apply to
ordinary humans.It's like Harakami-san's attack earlier
.  But if you change your name to Sora Note,
you can make a couple with anyone.In other
words, with this notebook, you can make an unlikely person fall in love.Do you
really want to be a couple?
I finally found you you see this
d  ai
yeah yeah tee
Everyone,
who is Senpai's feelings in red
?
This kind of feeling is
bad, so why is this person going to be Akane Zenmai's lover?
[Music]
ani
It wasn't me, was it
?  You're not my
little sister The tone is already blooming Yuzu My last name is different,
but you
're my sister  It's
fake, no, it's not fake Even without a notebook, I loved him, so I
'm okay, I made
you a couple Even though there's a maiden in love in front of me  I
can't just leave you alone as the shopkeeper,
you know? You read too much about the air, you're an idiot, and you
might end up becoming a lover
.  That's absolutely true
Onee-sama,
yes, it's cheating, isn't
it? It's a promise that I chose in the club.
The flames that came out,
God's mischief
, were you born?
[Applause]
[Music] It
was a clinic Otsuka woman who drew the degree of approval
.